foreign
hey you guys it's time once again for
flickers of fear my movie review show so
since I mentioned on a recent video I
don't know which one it was uh that I'd
actually been trying to watch some of
the newer films that have recently been
added to shutter because they've been
adding a lot of stuff like they add old
stuff too but they added a bunch of new
movies and I'd kind of gotten behind on
them so I think I mentioned that on a
video before and I was very happy to get
a recommendation from someone who was
listening
um and they told me that I should watch
the 2022 film speak no evil which
actually premiered earlier this year I
think it was in January of 2022 at
Sundance now I will note that although
the movie is Danish it's a Danish
production uh most of the movie is in
English it's not dubbed or anything the
characters are actually speaking English
there is some Danish and some Dutch in
there but it's almost all of it is in
English now while I will say that I
really really liked this movie it's
definitely not for everybody I know
nothing is but you know I just like to
put that out there I know it's kind of a
cliche to say slow burn but it is a kind
of a slow burn it doesn't really go full
on horror until the third act it's kind
of more of a psychological Thriller up
to that point and um another thing that
I saw another very common criticism that
I saw because some people that I saw
like really really hated it they said
that mostly their uh kind of their
dislike of it stemmed from their
frustration by the actions or you know
lack of action by certain characters but
uh that actually didn't bother me in
this latest I can see why it would but
it didn't really bother me I actually
found this movie
just sickeningly anxiety inducing
um and actually it was one that the
whole time I was watching it I was like
sitting there going how would I react
like if I was put into the same
situation as the protagonist at what
point would I say enough you know what I
mean and I kind of feel like that's one
of the cool things about this movie is
that you can sort of put yourself into
the character's shoes and be like oh
well I would have done this differently
I would have done that or I might have
done that as well you know what I mean
it's that kind of thing so the movie I I
kind of feel like it essentially like
gaslights the audience like a little bit
it kind of makes you it's very squirm
inducing also because it's kind of one
of those movies that makes you like
you're watching characters like um
insidiously Crossing other characters
boundaries but not necessarily in a way
that would cause the average person to
like flee and tear or be like oh no hell
no you know what I mean like at least
initially it's kind of like I saw
another reviewer I think it was spooky
astronauts and she brought up the movie
she's like it's nothing like this one
but in a way it kind of is she brought
up the movie compliance which was
actually based on a true story because I
mean thematically it's kind of similar
but it's internally it's not the same at
all but thematically it's kind of
similar now I will say that this movie
is not a fun watch at all uh it goes to
some pretty bleak places uh at the end
so if you're really not in the mood to
watch something like kind of depressing
and uh you know maybe even outright Soul
killing like depending on your point of
view then maybe you might want to give
this one a pass it's not a fun time and
I'm gonna say that right now so this was
directed by a fella named Christian
taftrup and I'm sure I'm probably
pronouncing that wrong so I apologize uh
it was co-written by him and his brother
mads now the movie is most obvious
comparison I think every review that I
watched or read of this uh brought up
Michael hanuki's uh funny games so it's
kind of along the same lines as that but
more generally it's just this movie is
just like a really good entry into that
you know kind of not actually as small
as I was uh thinking but it's this kind
of psychological horror sub-genre that
is sort of like social Horror in a way
it's kind of exploring the lengths that
people will go to in order to be polite
and to avoid causing conflict or
embarrassment like to other people and
how much we're willing to put up with
like in order to accommodate others so
in that way I don't want to go too far
in this direction but slightly this
movie kind of almost plays like an
extremely dark like cringe comedy at
times because most of it's like very
very awkward but
um also it has this really really
steadily escalating you know steadily
escalating tension throughout the whole
movie that even if you kind of like
laugh at some of the situations like
it'll just be like a really really
awkward uneasy kind of laugh because you
just know that something bad is going on
but you don't know exactly what it is
and you don't know like when it's coming
so it's just kind of like like I said
it's just kind of gives you this like
really really bad bad feeling like in
the pit of your stomach like pretty much
from the first you know frame so at the
beginning of the story we meet a Danish
family uh the dad's name is Bjorn the
mom's name is Louise or Louisa and the
daughter's name is uh Agnes or anyas as
they would say over there uh and they're
on a vacation in Tuscany in Italy now
not too long into their holiday they
meet this very very friendly Dutch
family who it looks like is staying at
the same hotel or Resort as they are so
this Dutch family uh the dad's name is
Patrick the mom's name is Karen and they
have this really really shy uh son named
Abel or Abel and he doesn't really talk
all that much Patrick actually explains
later on that he has some congenital uh
deformity like he didn't have like he
was born without a tongue or with like a
really small tongue so he can't really
talk all that much or when he talks like
you can't really understand what he's
saying now from the jump it's pretty
clear that from the way that the
families and specifically the men
interact and this is actually really
really beautifully and subtly portrayed
through just kind of random bits of
seemingly trivial dialogue like body
language and like significant glances
and things like that but you can tell
that Bjorn sees in Patrick the kind of
man that he would like to be
so Bjorn the character is kind of like a
passive guy uh he very much clearly
loves his wife and family but he sort of
maybe low-key laments the lack of
passion and excitement in his life he's
always kind of like been one of those
guys that followed the rules he's always
done what he was supposed to do what was
expected of him and has kind of hence
come to this place in his life where he
sort of feels like unfulfilled as though
he's become like just some guy who ended
up in this like really humdrum existence
through his own like lack of
assertiveness like he's never been able
to like jump up and like grab Life by
the balls or anything like that and so
he's just sort of like ended up here
through no will of his owner because he
didn't have enough will going forward
and Patrick the Dutch guy by contrast is
actually this really really very very
vibrantly masculine he's very like
outgoing and very gregarious and he's
just kind of like one of those Grill
Gruff like friendly opens you know what
I mean and he's always kind of like
talking to every everybody and making
everybody laugh and stuff like that and
the way that he is you can see that
Bjorn obviously like really admires him
and really like aspires to be that way
even though he's not so and you can even
see like Bjorn he visibly like kind of
inflates and like stands taller after
Patrick calls him heroic for going back
like Bjorn goes back to like his
daughter like loses her little stuffed
bunny
that she loves and he goes back and like
goes through the streets and finds it
for her and he calls her heroic and he's
like no no I'm serious
um and that actually the whole bunny
thing like foreshadows like some kind of
more Sinister [ __ ] that happens later on
um but from that interaction which
happens like early on when they're still
in Tuscany you immediately understand
that Patrick is maybe buttering Bjorn up
for some unknown purpose so the families
have a really Pleasant vacation uh you
know hanging out with one another going
out to dinner together blah blah blah
and then they go back to their
respective countries now sometime later
it's not real clear how long it is but
Bjorn and Louise get a postcard from the
Dutch couple and it's inviting them to
come spend the weekend with them like in
their house in this sort of like remote
Countryside of the Southern Netherlands
now Louise is kind of I guess like
understandably reluctant she's like look
Patrick and Karen we barely know them
it's just like we hung out with them
like a few days like on vacation they're
practically strangers to us but it's
pretty evident that Bjorn really really
wants to go also I kind of feel like
they knew what would get them to come
there too because the postcard also says
oh little Abel their little son he
really really wants to see um Anya's
again you know their daughter and uh
that kind of gives Bjorn all the
justification he needs oh that poor kid
like he misses our daughter how can we
like deny you know what I mean so it's
that kind of thing so they set out on
the eight hour drive like you know
Louise is trying to be like yeah but we
already like spend all this money like
on flights this year in blah blah he's
like we'll drive it's only eight hours
blah blah so they end up like driving
there so everything seems mostly fine at
first uh Patrick and Karen seem like
very genial hosts and they have kind of
their house like I said is kind of out
in the middle of nowhere it's kind of
like a little bit it's big but it's kind
of like shabby or but it's like kind of
comfortable like you can tell it's like
very very lived in
um which is kind of in contrast to the
Danish couples like very very well
appointed like very very nice kind of
clean area you know what I mean but uh
right from the start as you might
imagine lots of very very small and
seemingly inconsequential occurrences
slowly begin to sour the experience for
the Danes now one of the things is that
Patrick apparently forgot that Louise
was a vegetarian which she did actually
tell him and they had a discussion about
while they were on vacation and so Pat
and Patrick seems to be making a point
of like cooking really meat heavy dishes
and very insistently like cajoling her
into tasting them and it's like you can
tell she's like no that's okay I'm you
know I'm a vegetarian he's like oh well
you know you can just which is this one
bite you know what I mean and finally
she just like gives in because he just
keeps you know at her you know what I
mean not in a mean way but just you know
you know how that goes like when you go
to somebody's house and they're like oh
I made this you know cake or something
like that and you're like look I really
don't want any and it's just like they
just keep at you and keep edging your
five fine okay just like leave me the
[ __ ] alone because most people don't
want to just like [ __ ] off I don't want
any you know what I mean even though
maybe you should which is which is
something that this movie actually
actually absolutely explores another
thing too is that Patrick and Karen have
set um Anya as the daughter here up on
this little bitty air mattress like in
the same room as their son Abel which
they think is a little bit weird and
they're like well you didn't even ask us
like how it is set up and it's just like
stuff like that
um also they don't seem to have Patrick
and Karen don't seem to have like any
kind of of your normal like social
boundaries or like propriety like
they'll walk into the bathroom to pee
like while you're in the shower like
that kind of [ __ ] like without even like
looking at you like oh whatever like
it's the most normal thing in the world
so you know it's a little bit weird and
then a bit later on like Patrick and
Karen invite the Danish couple out to a
restaurant but they don't tell them
until they're literally like walking out
the door that oh the kids aren't coming
with us like because they assumed that
the daughter was coming with them too
um but yeah it's like oh the kid no kids
tonight you know what I mean and they're
being left with this babysitter who
Bjorn and Louise have obviously never
met before who's another stranger to
them and then while they're at the
restaurant like they go along with that
um even though they're not happy about
it and then when they're at the
restaurant like Patrick and Karen kind
of get like really drunk and they start
like uh you know dancing when it was
like really really provocatively and
like kind of like you know in a get a
room kind of way uh which makes the
other couple like really really
uncomfortable and they also very subtly
like manipulate Bjorn into paying the uh
not insubstantial check uh which he's
like oh somebody had a good time and
he's like oh so we're paying it he's
like oh thanks man it was that kind of
thing uh Patrick also drives home drunk
like weaving all over the road which is
thankfully deserted at that time of
night blaring the radio like at top
volume even though Louise is like hey
can you turn the [ __ ] music down it's
like blasting our ears out [ __ ] like
that now Louise uh in fact uh grows
tired of the Dutch couple pretty quickly
and I can totally see why because this
would not be a fun time now she makes it
very clear to her husband Bjorn that she
would like to leave now Bjorn does not
really want to go
um because he kind of like feels like I
said he feels very invigorated by
Patrick in this unabashed like machismo
that he has uh but he eventually is like
okay maybe you're right so they kind of
sneak out but then they kind of get
busted and then and like the couple like
Patrick and Karen when they're
confronted about they're like oh my God
we can't believe like you guys would
just like leave without saying goodbye
um but then like Louise starts telling
them like all these things but when she
kind of lists it it sounds like so so
insignificant like all the stuff that
she's complaining about and then Patrick
and Karen are like oh my God we're so
sorry we're so sorry and they have like
an explanation for every single
grievance that the other couple have
brought up and then they even kind of
like flip it a little bit like very
craftily and like play the victim card
they're like oh well maybe it's just
like a cultural misunderstanding like
you Danes you know and your thing and
whatever and like the Dutch do it like
this and blah blah blah um and you maybe
you guys are just kind of uptight or
whatever so through all of this kind of
like duplicitous uh [ __ ] they are
actually able to convince Bjorn and
Louise to stay for the rest of the
weekend simply by exploiting their
disinclination to be rude to people who
have you know supposedly been so
friendly and generous like opening up
their home to them and like hook looking
for them and stuff like that so from
there as you might expect uh things take
a very very very dark turn and trust me
when I say the ending of this of the
ending of this movie is like pretty
[ __ ] Grim now while the character of
Bjorn in particular is very frustrating
and I get that
um I mean there's a bunch of points in
the story where he absolutely should
have like nutted up and put his foot
down rather than going along with
situations that were clearly going south
um he's also not all that unrealistic I
didn't find and to be honest his
passivity is actually like a big part of
the theme or the message of the movie if
you want to call it that which is
actually kind of like a like almost like
a really really dark satire on excessive
politeness and how it can absolutely get
you into real trouble if you don't know
like when or how you need to like stand
up for yourself
um from what I could gather this was
like really interesting to me
um I read some comments from people who
had seen it who were actually Danish
according to them like they the
particular choice of making the Danish
couple like super Bourgeois and like
unwilling to rock the boat and very
uptight and kind of then pitting them
against the very stereotypically more
open and convivial like a Dutch couple
which I guess like I said their cultural
stereotypes that it's sort of skewering
a little bit
um it kind of like gave the movie for
them like a a real particular like
cultural resonance I guess and a lot of
like cruel humor I think they found it a
lot funnier uh than Americans did
because they could relate like to the
cultural stereotypes that were being
satirized I mean obviously I can't
really speak to that but since I am
neither Danish nor Dutch but however I
am kind of like a laid back sort of
introverted person who also really
dislikes confrontation uh so I could
actually completely relate to the Dane's
predicament although I will say that I
like to think that I would have noped
out like way earlier than they did but
on the other hand I can understand like
how they ended up staying as long as
they did and how it ended up going but
that's C that's the thing that's the
hell of it and that's why I'm still
thinking about this [ __ ] movie is
that do any of us really know like how
much of this we would take unless we
were actually like confronted with these
exact circumstances you know what I'm
saying and I think that's where uh you
know when I saw in spooky astronauts
Channel where she compared this a little
bit to compliance
um if you've seen that I don't want to
go into that because that's like a whole
other review but it's a similar kind of
thing where it's like a frog in boiling
water it's like At first like the
requests that people are making or the
things that people are doing don't seem
all that bad or that egregious but then
like it slowly like ramps up and then
suddenly you're like how the [ __ ] did I
get in this situation
um just because you you let the guy like
get get away with all this kind of stuff
and then he just kept like upping the
ante you know what I mean so as I
mentioned speak no evil is technically
more of a psychological Thriller at
least for the first two acts but it does
go to some very disturbed serving places
toward the end so don't watch this if
you're in the mood for just like a
bloody good time that you don't can just
turn off your brain because if you do
that like this movie will probably just
make you like really angry and bummed
out so I am saying that so like I said
while it does kind of
skewer the character of Bjorn in
particular for him being so like docile
and kind of like gets on him for his
responsibility like to what extent is he
responsible for the horrors that
ultimately unfold it's also it's not
just picking on him though it's also
indicting the Dutch characters who while
on the surface like seem more admirable
because they're extroverted and more
sociable and things like that but that
you know this veneer also like masks
this real like depravity in this real
evil that's like lurking beneath so it's
kind of like you know it's kind of
skewering both things like I said it's a
satire but it's not funny but I don't
know that might depend on your
perspective like I said if it's if it's
humorous it's like it's super super
black humor you know what I mean I would
recommend this but really only to fans
of very restrained but very Bleak
psychological horror if you're a fan of
more kind of like overt horror more
traditional horror you'd probably find
it you know too slow or too frustrating
too maddening it's like why is this guy
doing more why you know why are they
still there why is this that but like I
said that's kind of the whole point of
the film is it's explore boring it's
exploring people's boundaries and like
how uh you know how how much would it
take to like push them and how would you
get into this kind of situation as well
just through your own like wish to not
rock the boat like I said that's kind of
like what the what the movie is
exploring so that's why the characters
are like that
um and as I said this is definitely a
movie that I'm going to be thinking
about for a while just because of the
[ __ ] that happened and kind of like
wondering about myself and like what if
I was in this situation like you know
what I'd like to think that I wouldn't
have gone that far but it's like I don't
know as you know I've never been in a
situation like this really but yeah it's
so it's one of those ones that really
kind of makes you think afterward so
this is actually on shutter you can
probably find it on other uh streaming
services well I think I saw it for rent
on Amazon Prime as well but I watched it
on shutter and it's uh just got added
there not too long ago so check it out
if it sounded at all interesting to you
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear I will see you guys again on the
next one bye